you know this is an exit poll there are
lots of question marks over you know it
may not necessarily be fully reliable
but over the past few decades it
certainly has been let's have a look
though out those numbers provides those
out the way three hundred and
sixty-eight seats for the Conservatives
it's not just a good night a great night
for the Tories Boris Johnson could win
360 ACS would give them a majority in
government quite clearly actually have a
look how that actually works out so
there we have the numbers but let's put
them into our kind of virtual House of
Commons so there you have it it's our
government builder essentially taking
all of those parties all of those
results this is from the exit poll let's
put the conservative numbers into the
government benches as it were so those
hexagons represent government benches
and that line look at that line that's
326 seats it takes the Tories
comfortably pass the total they require
to get into Downing Street you'll
remember that winning line we showed you
earlier on the line into Downing Street
according to the exit poll Boris Johnson
is safely in but it is of course
according to the accept poll now the
poll also suggesting maybe even more of
a story labour to get a hundred and
ninety-one seats leaving them short
obviously of being able to form a
coalition challenge the Conservative
Party historically bad worse since the
second world war as you were hearing
you're talking to Debbie Barry garden or
a moment ago I mean many people think
we'll think that's pretty disastrous for
the Labour Party let's just go back
though that's the exit poll let's go
back and remember the picture in 2017
okay so have a look at this will show
you the results last time around so 2017
the Tories 318 short of that majority
there you can see the board on the Left
Labour 262 so up above 200 that time
around and then you can see the map
behind that's the map as of before today
the map of the UK the political map is
about to be redrawn let's clear that
it's clear so we're starting afresh and
throughout the evening that map's gonna
be very important because we're going to
be keeping a very close eye on
constituencies around the country there
you can see them dotted so those good
Citroen C's around the country we're
looking at to see if that exit poll is
on track or not that's